all right edwina
edwina where are you from originally
where did you grow up i grew up in
clinton oklahoma
but um i was born in fort lauderdale
florida we had moved to oklahoma when i
was five years old meet my mom and dad
that's when they split up for good they
have been together for like seven years
um when
how was your childhood
i can remember way back when i was three
years old in florida
sitting at a breakfast table with my mom
and dad and they had a fifth of a half a
gallon of vodka sitting in the middle of
the table
i remember this and flip wilson was
playing on tv
um my mom used to take my beatings for
me my dad used to was very abusive to my
mom
i had got bit by a dog when i was four
um in my shoulder
and it was one of them rottweilers that
were trying to kill the wild boars out
of the everglades and she had puppies
and i picked one up and
she attacked me if the owner didn't come
out she would have got she would have
bit my jugular vein but
where she bit my shoulder and she tried
to go for my neck i
moved and i got her scratches on my neck
but
when the ambulance was called and the
police was called
my mom and dad didn't know had no idea i
went outside i snuck outside because i
wanted to go play and my dad was going
to beat me because i wanted to go play
but my mom took my beating for me
when the police showed up and to go get
my mom and dad
they found my mom all beat up and my dad
was drunk and all this and still beating
on her
when they got there they took him to
jail and got him for
a child endangerment
spousal abuse neglect
and other things
my dad spent six months in jail and got
back out
and that's when we have moved
from florida to oklahoma i'm only going
um
on my dad's side for my dad i have five
other brother
one brother and four other sisters
there's six of us
but with my mom i'm an only child i'm
the only time my mom had
so my grandpa on my mom's side
my mom's dad i was the only grandchild
so i was spoiled
through him that's the only love i have
ever known
genuine love
my grandpa raised my mom from um
raised my mom and my brother and her
brother my uncle
my mother my grandmother died giving
birth to my mother
so my mother never knew her mom and
so she never really got the raise
bringing of a of a woman
thing from a mother you know which i
never did either because my mom
never raised me i was ready like i said
when i was in first grade i got molested
by my step-dad
and um from then on it was like
that's how my childhood was you know my
only serenity was going to school
and then i don't know
it's just like i was a lazy child you
know i really didn't want to do anything
or whatever
and i got pregnant when i was 13
with my son brandon and went into a
wedding mother's home they took my
mother's rights for me
of me from my mother and put me in a
foster home
and when i had my son
uh i stayed with i stayed in that foster
hometown i was 18.
who is the father his name is um
hold on
vandon his name is brandon um
perchie he um he's pr he's done passed
away already
he's probably gone um i haven't been to
oklahoma since i've been out here
i've been out here 18 years
i had my my oldest daughter when i was
22. so there's 95 years difference
between my son and my daughter
and then there's like two years
difference between my other kids i got
five kids
me and my ex-husband got revenued our
vows in
1989. uh
we make we when we go back 1997
we renewed our vows the church that we
renewed our vows in the preacher
gave the sermon to my daughter's funeral
nine days later
i was in a house fire my house caught on
fire my apartment
and my baby was i left my baby up and i
got blown
i know what it feels like for a house to
take a breath because my house took a
breath and blew me out the window
i weighed 360 pounds um
i was big i was a big big big big lady
and um because no one told me i wasn't
supposed to gain 100 pounds when i was
pregnant
that 13 but uh
so i had always been big you know don't
know i never did
never knew nothing any underneath 100
pounds or whatever
or 150 pounds or
but um i got blown out of a window
probably about about this white it was
an old window pane
thing and and you raised the window up
like this
and um the paint got stuck and i
couldn't get out and i busted the window
which i shouldn't have because the
oxygen hit the fire
and it blew my house my apartment
i got blown 30 feet out the window out
of a piece of glasses to be
360 pounds i had no idea how it happened
but it's like somebody just grabbed me
and jerked me through there
i had no cuts no nothing but i got i was
burnt
27 in my body i spent 18 days in
hospital
um we buried my daughter on the 26th of
december it happened december 22 1997.
they pronounced her dead at 3 34 a.m
um fire department was blocked from my
house
you could see it took him four minutes
to get there four minutes to put it out
she was gone by then i don't remember
much that
night i couldn't even tell you where my
kids were um but i know they were safe
that wasn't burnt
um
i went through pain i know
i faced my worst fear uh my feared
fire you know my house catching on fire
you know whatever
it wasn't my fault it was uh my hot
water heater blew up
this is what happened i had a defective
hot water heater and it blew out i had
to settle out of court
for 275 000 because i had a
racist judge and i lived in a racist
town
indians in oklahoma are the minorities
because we have casinos we have we don't
pay taxes and all this and this and it's
like
you know they have a they're it's you
know
they look down on indians plus they
don't help when our when the indian men
go out and get a job and work the first
to the first paycheck and then they'll
go back to work you know
um my ex-husband
he was a supervisor at a pipeline
company
and he uh
worked at a lucky lucky star uh
on his days off so
i never really worked i stayed home took
care of the kids
and um went and played bingo
drank became a big alcoholic
i drank a lot a lot lot
but my biggest my
my thing i'm a pisces i haven't fantasy
world
and i live in a fantasy world um
i want the knight in shining armor and
and the white horses
and all this to come carry me away and
live happily ever after and
that never happens um
i followed my mother's footsteps my
mother left me with my my
with my relatives to chase her men into
her drink
because she became an alcoholic real bad
and
i came out here i left a four bedroom
brick home
to come out here to california to sleep
on the sidewalk
with somebody i didn't even know i left
my marriage and my kids abandoned my
marriage and my kids
my kids was little my baby was in the
hospital she was four years old
and she was gonna die the doctor told me
there was nothing they could do for her
that it was going
but it was up to her whether she wanted
to live or die
she had called a virus and it went into
her bloodstream
and it started shutting down her organs
i didn't see my baby again until she was
19. she turned 20 out here
i haven't seen my other two kids i
haven't seen my son since he was
four he don't acknowledge me he's
his mother's gone he's dead he don't
have no mother
which i can accept that i did that to my
children
um
i just now recently started talking back
to my kids like about maybe
eight or nine years ago um
i came out here started smoking crack
and i smoked crack on these streets day
in
day out 24 7 for 10 years
i quit smoking crack about
six years ago it's been about six six
years ago six seven years ago
um i couldn't do it anymore i couldn't
wake up without nothing i couldn't even
go buy me a 50 cent soda you know
and i justify it as
you know but it's switching from one
drug to the other
you know but crystal man i think crystal
meth saved my my life
i switch from crack to crystal
and i can do things
i smoke me a bow go out handle my
business do whatever i gotta do
and i'm good do i smoke crack all bets
are off
i won't look like this i'll be sitting
out there on the sidewalk
wondering what happened to me how did i
get like this again because my head tell
me
go get a hit it's all it takes one hit
i love crack it's crazy i love it
i was smoking today if i could i really
would
smoke like a broke stove but i can't
because i can't deal with my
consequences behind my actions
the things that i would do for it i
can't deal with that
i spent seven years seven months in
um twin towers for it
on two possession charges and
um judge gave me 16 months with 10
months credit
i did seven months
and came out with no paper no no parole
no paper no nothing
and um that's the best thing i ever did
when i came out here when i first came
out here i weighed 360 pounds i went
from 360 to 135 pounds in nine months
smoking crap i used to say if genie
craig can't
do it crack can to be my motto
um then i started smoking clear crystal
and i was a lot better
i was more it helped me more
conscientious about my parents about
a lot of things but i think it saved me
because
i would have somebody was going to die
if i kept smoking crack
and drinking alcohol i had to quit
drinking too i'm big i love alcohol
i had to quit drinking too because
somebody like i said somebody was going
to die
i was either going to kill somebody or
somebody was going to kill me behind it
because i was doing scanless things i
come too in a [ __ ] alley on my knees
second dick
excuse my language we're hand to crack
and i thought what are you doing you
know
where's your morals these are standards
that you would said you would never
cross
look at you you're crossing them i talk
to myself like that all the time i have
to because i'm the
i'm the only person that i can talk to i
can't trust these people out here
none of them you know they would stab
you in the back in a minute
take what you got and stab you in the
neck but you're they're your friends
they got you back yeah right okay
how many times i heard that your little
doorman over here he um
yeah he he was a negative part
to my upbringing out here um
we don't get along you don't like me i
don't like him
you know he uh couldn't get me to do
what he wanted me to do and
out here and and uh because i don't go
with these guys out here
i date i'm whole can i say no
i sell condoms 20 bucks pop
um told judge that one time gave me 60
days
um he'd pick up these girls and
and get him to go smoke or whatever
whatever and when the dope was gone
he put him out on a blade and like i
said i don't mess with these guys out
here
because i don't feel that my name should
be coming out of their mouth or they
could sit around the [ __ ]
sit around in a circle shooting dice
talking about did you know chyna has
some good head or
damn her pussy's gear you know they do
that to all these females out here
and i value myself you know
a lot more than that even though i smoke
crack or whatever
i still value my you know myself
um if you ain't got a job if you ain't
got a house
or you ain't got a car you know i don't
go in the alleys
i'm scared to death of allies um
i was raped out here once i was
robbed by gunpoint once
and i recently sent him into prison for
no less than 22 years for robbing me and
criminal threats
because he wanted to be a pimp and
i refused to be his whole
so nobody would help me so i ended up
calling police because he took my bike
it wasn't my bike but he took it
regardless
and i took him to court i had a witness
my witness testified with me we went to
court five times and he stayed with me
he went through
he smokes crack you know i went to
treatment with him i mean he was in
treatment center i went to impact
i did impact out of my two possession
charges
they gave me drug court judge titan yes
and i did impact it gave me 18 months it
was 18 month program
i did 15 months and relapse
right out here two blocks down um
leap year day drink a beer
in my best thinking set let's go take a
hit
and i went on 18 day run and they caught
up with me
and when i went to court the judge i
told the judge i'm not
i'm not doing this treatment no more i'm
not because i gave up 18 months credit
to go back into treatment i didn't know
nothing about the credit system
because in oklahoma you get popular
anything like this
you're going to sit maybe a month in
jail before you even go see the judge
dead time you don't start don't your
sins don't start until you go
get sentencing go to prison or go to
jail whatever to get sentenced
here you guys got the little vacation
you know so you go in you out the next
day
um the criticism right here
as remarkable first time i
went to jail they gave me 45 days for
prostitution i have nine prostitutions
under me
but they can only count to uh seven they
had to strike two
um jumped in the car police every time
but my best thinking told me to go and i
was mad
at my boyfriend or i was upset i wasn't
thinking i wasn't paying attention to my
surroundings and this and this and i'm
just going to go get that money and woo
and there i go jumped in the car with
police wouldn't pay no attention that
there was
undercover over here and squad cars over
here and
you know
when i quit smoking crack and went to
crystal i got real skinny
i thought that's a [ __ ] um i've been i
have been
small since i've been out here my
ex-husband's never seen me little like
this he's seen me big he's
you know when he finally seen me little
he told me i was dainty
oh you're so dainty i'm scared just
break you
my kids have never seen me little
um when my daughter angela came out here
she um was amazed that i could put her
jeans on
you can't fit my jeans yes i can i bet
you i can fit your jeans i've heard
jeans on she wear a size 12. i could fit
a 12.
she was amazed by that um she got
pregnant out here she stayed out here
seven months
my daughter got me on zola because
everything i said to my mother when i
was at age
i said to her my mother said to me i
said to her
and it was like watching my my daughter
through a bubble and i couldn't do
nothing about it because she rubbed it
in my face all the time that i left her
i abandoned her and her sisters and left
her and
and um i had no right to tell her
anything
when she told me that she was grown and
she could do whatever the [ __ ] she
wanted to
i told her okay you go be grown just
like my mama told me
she packed up all my stuff put it out on
the front porch pushed me out the door
and told me go be grown
that night i got beat up by my by my
son's dad
he beat me up really really beat me up
i couldn't open my eyes the next morning
i couldn't
i couldn't move i had bruises on top of
bruises i had
footprint right here
i was 20 years old when that happened
and that was the last time i ever told i
said i was ever going to let any man hit
me
because i was not going to look like my
mom
my mom's got scar tissue all over her
face from being beat up by men
you know she always picked the bad ones
that wanted to beat her but she loved
them
my mother was indian liz they called her
indian liz because she had
hundreds of boyfriends or men that she
married or whatever she had
a different name every weekend getting
inaudible
every weekend or whatever um my mama was
cool though
she was really cool she died at 52. i'm
i'll be 53 in march
i've been out here since i was 38 years
old
i grew up out here um just when i left
oklahoma my best thinking told me that
my kids would be better off with their
dad
and i need to go sew my oats somewhere
in california
and that's what i did i haven't been
back
but like i said um i've been in contact
with my ex-husband and and you know
he still remembers a lot of things that
i forgot you know he brings him up and
and we talk about him and i'm like oh
yeah right oh okay
but um i never really realized how much
he really really loved me
you know until we started talking and
i really really hurt this man i hurt him
by doing what i did i hurt my girls
you know so i never was really a mother
you know i mean a mom she said i'm a
mother
but i was never a mom or mommy or you
know i didn't take the kids to
soccer practices or any of that
um i did once go threaten the teacher to
be
with her ass when she let my daughter
get beat up at school
and my daughter got suspended i was
drunk
my daughter knew i was drunk she said no
mom don't go just stay here it's okay
no it's not we went up there and about
yeah
pulled that woman through that that door
but um
my daughter stopped me she was in first
grade imagine that
i was a very mean drunk when i was when
i drank very mean drunk
i used to go to the voa and sober up get
out get out of here for a while
go volunteer laundry be clean for a
while get all this stuff and then
get a wire hair up my butt and go take a
walk and people they want they wouldn't
see me for
two three weeks i'd be out here off on a
stick one
smoking crack trying to get every kid
you know every hit i could find
but if i didn't have the money
somebody's gonna give me some crack
somebody was gonna come out of their
pocket
or sell their ass or sell their shoes or
sell their clothes do something get me
some crap
that's the kind of crackhead i am you
know i'm that one
i've never stole from my family though
um i've never stole anything
out here from anybody i don't steal i
can't i don't i stole a pack of gum one
time and got
severely beat by my mom and so i never
stole it again
um i don't like a liar and i don't like
thieves
you know i'm not saying i never lied you
know
everybody lies of course i lied when it
was
appropriate you know but um to really
honestly to
to just sit here and lie to you i
couldn't do that you could tell when i'm
lying
start stuttering and you know i look
really guilty when i'm lying
you just spot it right away um
i've been in relationships out here
three serious relationships
out of the 18 years i've been out here
um this last one
i'm still in kinda sorta when he wants
it to be
it's been three years we've been
together and
i left i was on my way back to oklahoma
when he called me back and told me to
come back
i should have never i should never
turned around i just kept on going
um
i've sold down a lot i don't come out
here like i used to i work off my phone
i got maybe about six clients that i see
now compared to all the men that i had
out here
i can say i know what i'm doing i'm very
good at what i do
i take pride in my job or my career
or whatever you want to call it my camp
my condom selling
uh and but um
like i said i'll be 53 years old
i'm glad i aged very very well you know
i'm very glad that i aged very well
if i would have stayed in oklahoma i
think i would be dead by now because i
was so heavy and so big
um i think crack really saved my life it
really did
you know it made me lose all that weight
and everything and
couldn't tell me that i was into [ __ ] my
head was this big
i was this little you know and and i
thought i looked good
until they took my picture my mug shot
picture and i looked at it and i was
like wow
walking dead for real um
that's about it uh
i smoke weed i don't drink anymore
oh um my daughter just recently got
killed
my youngest one that came out here they
found her new year's eve
in the back of a car just two weeks ago
they buried her january 6th
[ __ ] cut her throat
cut her throat she was 25 years old so
whatever he cut her throat
he i don't know i don't know the details
my ex-husband won't tell me i don't know
the details but
yeah he cut her throat and left on the
back of abandoned car
so here lately i've been on a sick one
and uh i think i recently sobered up
like about
five days ago i was i've been drinking
i've been crying and
but she wouldn't want that
you know so i think i'm done with that
you know i let i let her go and and said
my little prayer for her
and and did my little ritual and i'm
good
she's now trying to stay away from these
[ __ ] and
not have to worry about them bothering
me i moved out away from here i had to
get away from here to get away from
crack
so i moved on that side and i live in a
tent
i've been living there for three years
in this tent never had a ten in my life
now
suddenly i get a tent and i got three
cats and a dog
that i take care of and a
cheating old man so but that's my little
life in a nutshell
and um thank you for interviewing me
thank you very much for coming in you're
welcome great story
you